hey this is presh talwalker you may know
me from videos about the internet's
favorite math topic the order of
operations it seems that students today
have tremendous difficulty with the
order of operations but I'm here to tell
you don't blame social media I want to
present a problem that gave students
difficulty in the pre-internet days
this is a question that was given to 17
to 18 year old students in America in
the year 1992.
what is 3 to the power of 3 plus 4
parentheses 8 minus five close
parentheses divided by 6 equal to
this is a multiple choice question the
choices are a 6.5 B 11 c 27.5 d 29 and E
34.16
calculators are allowed on the question
from a survey done in 1992
71 percent of students gave the wrong
answer so how do we figure out this
question
let's work it out
one way to work through the order of
operations is to use the acronym PEMDAS
this refers to evaluating parentheses
first then exponents then do
multiplication and division and finally
do addition and subtraction
you may have also learned the acronym
badmas in which parentheses has the
corresponding word brackets and
exponents has the corresponding word
orders
if you have two operations of the same
precedence you want to evaluate from
left to right
first we have a parenthetical expression
of eight minus five
this is equal to three so we'll
substitute in
then we have an exponent of 3 to the
power of three
that's equal to 27.
finally we have a multiplication of four
times three and we want to divide this
by six so we have a multiplication and a
division so we have two operations of
the same precedence so we'll evaluate
from left to right
4 times 3 is equal to 12 so we'll
substitute in then 12 divided by 6 is
equal to 2. so we'll substitute in
finally we want to add 27 and 2 and we
get the correct answer of 29. before I
get to how students responded let me
give a brief note about the use of the
division symbol the government of
Australia actually has a style guide in
which the section on Division and
multiplication States the following
you can use the mathematical symbol for
the division sign
or the division slash to show division
people sometimes use the forward slash
to show division as well in most cases
it's best to use the division sign the
division slash is easily confused with
the forward slash which is also used to
show alternatives
so there are valid reasons to use the
division symbol and we should all
understand how to evaluate it properly
so where did students go wrong
the correct answer is d29
but here's how the students responded 40
gave the wrong answer of 6.5 and the
next wrong answer was 34.16 at 15 after
that it was the answer of 11 with 10 and
the answer of 27.5 at 5 a small
percentage of students two percent
omitted the question altogether
now for fun I did a poll on YouTube
which got 41 000 responses
overwhelmingly 89 gave the correct
answer of d
so where did they go wrong how did they
get the wrong answer
well 29 were able to get the correct
answer
but let's look at 6.5
they may have done the following if they
did the addition first and then divided
by six they would get the answer of 6.5
in other words they took everything to
the left of the division symbol as the
numerator and they took six as the
denominator
the next incorrect choice would be
because students concatenated the four
and the three together to get 43 instead
of multiplying them
the next common mistake was by taking
three times three instead of three to
the power of 3.
the final mistake was by omitting the
four before the parentheses
it's interesting to learn the ways in
which students struggle with the order
of operations
so I will continue to make videos from
time to time until hopefully everyone
will get the correct answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]